[Aplausos]
[Música]
no hay lugar a dudas la guerra comercial
es uno de los temas más calientes de la
política internacional
aquí en visual político ya os hemos
hablado en varios vídeos sobre las
consecuencias que puede tener que ya
está teniendo toda esta guerra comercial
sin embargo nos falta una pregunta que
muchos de vosotros nos habéis hecho
especialmente a través de nuestra página
de patria y que resulta fundamental para
analizar toda esta cuestión porque liam
3 los eeuu tienen un déficit comercial
tan grande a qué se debe
cuál es la causa de este gigantesco
agujero que en 2017 superó los 550 mil
millones de dólares y tal vez lo más
importante de todo cómo de grave es y
cómo ponerle remedio si puede que alguno
de vosotros esté pensando pues es muy
fácil si hay déficit comercial es porque
eeuu importa más de lo que exporta entre
otras cuestiones por la malvada
competencia desleal que ha
desindustrializado el país ergo si
castigamos las importaciones se reducirá
el déficit comercial verdad al fin y al
cabo este es el discurso de la casa
blanca
trump pues amigos esperar un momento
porque las cosas no son ni de lejos tan
fáciles atentos
[Música]
la ecuación fácil
escoger magnificar y denunciar un
problema ponen sobre la mesa un gran
número que todos podamos visualizar
crear y culpar a un enemigo que sea un
acierto eso da igual alertar de las
consecuencias y por último terminar con
un remedio tan simple y electoralista
como falso amigos estas son las claves
para crear un discurso político
populista un discurso que a la hora de
la verdad tal vez no sirve de nada pero
que te puede permitir ganar elecciones
pues bien esto es exactamente lo que
están haciendo en la casa blanca con el
objetivo de ganar votos han creado un
discurso político que por así decirlo se
sustenta fundamentalmente en una
ecuación con tres elementos
y tranquilos que esto no va de
matemáticas al menos novel todo
primer elemento el déficit comercial
causa daños terribles segundo elemento
todo es culpa de la competencia desleal
del resto de países especialmente de
china y como tercer elemento la amenaza
por culpa de todas esas malas artes del
resto de países la industria y el poder
de los eeuu se están viniendo abajo
sin embargo amigos una cosa es el
discurso y otra muy pero que muy
diferente la realidad veréis para
magnificar el problema los asesores
comerciales de donald trump alertan una
y otra vez sobre el impacto negativo que
todo este déficit comercial tiene sobre
la economía norteamericana para ello
utilizan esta identidad contable que
estáis viendo en pantalla que es una de
las fórmulas que se utilizan para
calcular el pib de esta forma el pib de
un país es igual al consumo más la
inversión más el gasto público más las
exportaciones menos las importaciones
vamos de primero de introducción a la
economía
el caso es que viéndolo de esta forma
parece que el dichoso déficit comercial
ocasiona un daño enorme a la economía de
eeuu y por supuesto si se reduce esa
diferencia entre las importaciones y las
exportaciones
entonces se incrementaría el pib
prosperidad para todos fácil verdad pues
espérate un momento porque todo esto
supone simplificar tanto las cosas que
al final cualquier parecido con la
realidad es pura coincidencia por qué
digo esto pues porque las relaciones con
el resto del mundo influyen mucho pero
que mucho en el resto de apartados que
conforman el pib
[Música]
al fin y al cabo cuando un extranjero
invierte en eeuu o cuando las empresas
norteamericanas compran materias primas
bienes de capital o bienes intermedios
el efecto sobre la economía no es
precisamente negativo todo lo contrario
si por ejemplo todos estos bienes se
encarecen por culpa de los aranceles
entonces las empresas pierden
competitividad de la misma forma
productos de importación más caros
afectarían también al sector minorista
de tal forma que al final la relación de
ese supuesto déficit comercial con el
pib no es ni mucho menos tan directa
como podría parecernos a simple vista el
segundo elemento que utiliza la casa
blanca es el de la competencia desleal
especialmente la de china
y claro supuestamente por culpa de las
malas artes de pekín el déficit de
bienes y servicios tan sólo con china
supera los 300 mil millones de dólares
al año
y ahí es cuando el presidente trans
piensa vamos a ver si reducimos el
déficit comercial con china entonces
problemas solucionado pues amigos en
este caso tampoco las cosas son así
primero lo de la competencia desleal es
cuando menos cuestionable se ha culpado
mucha china de manipular su divisa pues
lo cierto es que eso ya no es así de
hecho es todo lo contrario en los
últimos años el yuan chino se ha
apreciado bastante respecto al dólar y
sabéis que ha ocurrido con el déficit
comercial de eeuu con china cuando pekín
ha dejado de manipular de reevaluar su
moneda para exportar más pues que el
desvío se ha disparado
[Música]
pero como es esto posible pues amigos lo
cierto es que en realidad el déficit
comercial de estados unidos con asia
oriental en bienes manufacturados ha
sido más o menos constante desde
mediados de los años 90 lo que ha
cambiado es que lo que antes llegaba de
taiwán no de japón entre otros ahora
llega directamente desde china que se ha
convertido en el gran centro de
ensamblaje y esto es precisamente lo que
ha engordado tanto el déficit comercial
de eeuu con china
[Música]
y respecto al último punto en el
discurso de la casa blanca el de la
desindustrialización y pérdida de
competitividad por culpa de la
competencia desleal pues tampoco es
cierto las exportaciones de eeuu que
sigue siendo el segundo mayor exportador
del mundo se encuentra en niveles récord
lo mismo que en la producción industrial
fijaos
[Música]
no lo siento pero china no está
devorando la economía norteamericana
pero un momento entonces si los
argumentos de donald trump no son los
responsables de todo el comercial de
eeuu a qué se debe este desequilibrio
cuáles son sus auténticas razones
atentos
las verdaderas razones
puede que alguno de vosotros se
sorprenda pero lo cierto es que la culpa
del déficit comercial de eeuu no la
tiene la competencia desleal de ningún
país en este caso la culpa se queda en
casa si es posible que dejar de lado las
teorías que hablan de malvadas técnicas
chinas para destruir occidente sea mucho
menos apasionante pero lo siento así son
las cosas
[Música]
veréis la culpa del agujero comercial
está en la baja tasa de ahorro que
existe en los eeuu en la condición del
dólar como moneda de reserva lo que hace
que sea muy demandada y tiende a estar
sobrevalorada y también con la enorme
cantidad de capitales que todos los años
llegan a eeuu procedentes del extranjero
por ejemplo de china como vamos a ver
esto es lo que explica que eeuu lleve
más de 40 años con un déficit comercial
sin que la economía se resienta más de
40 años consecutivos consumiendo más de
lo que produce porque amigos
donald trump habla siempre de la balanza
comercial pero nunca habla de la balanza
financiera y ahí está la trampa
[Música]
un juego de pérdida absoluta
existe una ley económica que el
presidente de eeuu para hacer no haber
conocido nunca la balanza de pagos
siempre siempre está en equilibrio en un
sistema de tipos de cambios flotantes es
decir como el que se da hoy en día es
decir me explico un déficit comercial se
compensa básicamente con superávit en la
cuenta de capital o en la cuenta
financiera que para que nos entendamos
reflejan el saldo entre los capitales
que llegan al país y los que se marchan
vamos la pasta que entra en la pasta que
sale un persistente superávit en la
balanza por cuenta corriente se compensa
siempre con déficit en las cuentas de
capitales es una de las eternas leyes
económicas como la gravedad en la física
conrad put ser periodista del portal del
río
fijaos en lo que ha ocurrido
precisamente con la balanza de pagos de
eeuu
ahora bien quiere decir esto que un país
puede comprar en el extranjero lo que
quiera sin límites pues evidentemente no
sólo podrá importar si consigue
financiar o compensar sus importaciones
con capitales procedentes del extranjero
de no ser así primero su divisa se
depreciaría a un montón pura ley de la
oferta y la demanda mucha demanda de
moneda extranjera y poca de moneda local
y luego finalmente las reservas de
moneda extranjera del banco central se
terminarían desatándose con ello toda
una crisis cambiaria esto es algo que
latinoamérica especialmente en argentina
se conoce muy pero que muy bien pues
bien estados unidos es el mayor refugio
para capitales de todo el planeta
prácticamente la mitad del ahorro
mundial se termina invirtiendo en este
país ya sea en forma de préstamos de
inversión extranjera directa o comprando
acciones bonos etcétera etcétera
así que precisamente es todo este enorme
flujo de capitales lo que permite que
los estadounidenses consuman más de lo
que producen y que a pesar de llevar más
de 40 años consecutivos incurriendo en
déficits comerciales el país se
encuentre hoy prácticamente en pleno
empleo y en niveles récords como hemos
visto de exportaciones y producción
industrial ahora ya podemos entender
cosas como esta
ya sea japón en los 80 alemania en los
2000 o china en los últimos años los
países que han invertido fuertemente en
el mercado inmobiliario de nueva york
también tienden a tener un gigantesco
superávit comercial con eeuu con
rectitud ser periodista del portal de
radio es decir sintetizando gracias a
los capitales a la pasta que llega del
extranjero los eeuu se pueden permitir
el lujo de consumir más de lo que
producen por así decirlo además de
exportar bienes y servicios eeuu exportó
también títulos financieros pero un
momento quiere decir esto que no se
puede reducir el comercial para nada
[Música]
cómo reducir el déficit comercial como
veis las cosas a veces no son tal y como
parecen ser en un primer momento tener
un déficit comercial no tiene por qué
ser malo al fin y al cabo el objetivo
último de la economía tiene que ser
mejorar las condiciones de vida es decir
poder consumir más y mejores bienes y
servicios
pero eso sí un déficit comercial
abultado y continuo si supone por un
lado más riesgo riesgo de que los
capitales dejen de fluir hacia el país
lo que podría llevarle a sufrir una
importante crisis y por otro tienden a
favorecer el crecimiento de la deuda un
país inundado de dinero del extranjero
eso significa dinero abundante y barato
y amigos quien no quiere dinero barato
por tanto vayamos a la pregunta clave
cómo puede donald trump lograr reducir
el comercial de eeuu pues existen
principalmente tres opciones dos que es
mejor dejar de lado y una muy
recomendable
las dos primeras serían por un lado
ponerse de acuerdo con la reserva
federal para de evaluar el dólar y
lograr que deje de ser la moneda
hegemónica en el mundo así las
importaciones serían mucho más caras y
nadie querría llevar su dinero a este
país y por otro restringir los capitales
que pueden llegar del extranjero por
ejemplo mediante impuestos claro que eso
a la larga sería un desastre la otra
opción la recomendable es consumir menos
a ahorrar más y favorecer la inversión
productiva de esta forma se demandarían
menos préstamos del exterior y se
generaría mucha más riqueza de tal forma
que en términos relativos los
comerciales serían mucho más pequeños
pues bien para lograr este objetivo
frenar el cada vez mayor agujero fiscal
del gobierno sería una idea fantástica
pero desafortunadamente donald trump a
pesar de su discurso va en la dirección
contraria también sería una opción
fantástica por ejemplo permitir que las
empresas estadounidenses pudieran ocupar
los casi seis millones de puestos de
trabajo vacantes que hoy sufre la
economía de este país trayendo
profesionales del
en cambio las políticas proteccionistas
no funcionan primero porque el resto de
países suele responder a tus aranceles
con lo cual se reducen las importaciones
pero también las exportaciones y sobre
todo porque el incremento de costes que
suponen los aranceles hacen que eeuu sea
un país menos atractivo para invertir y
eso a la larga es algo malo muy malo
tal vez amigos la mejor prueba de que
las empresas norteamericanas necesitan
estar abiertas al mundo la encontramos
en la propia familia trampa si en la
familia trump tal cual como lo escucháis
sabíais que ivanka trump la hija del
presidente y asesora en la casa blanca
tiene una marca de moda de ropas y
zapatos pues a que no adivina es donde
fabrica sus productos tal vez en eeuu
error habéis fallado la respuesta
correcta es en china la mayor parte de
sus productos se fabrican en china y
luego también en países como vietnam e
indonesia y me preguntó será la propia
ivanka trump cómplice de los malvados
que están atacando eeuu con sus malas
artes comerciales ahí lo dejo
precisamente justo ahora en julio de
2018 y tras las críticas por tantas
contradicciones y una abultada caída en
sus ventas
ivanka trump ha anunciado el cierre de
su línea de moda y complementos ahora si
te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
echarnos una mano dándole a like y
suscribiéndote abisal político si aún no
lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
dicen temer 66 el viento
wiggins entre